yet another book of yours is sell your
story to Hollywood the writers pocket
guide that the business of show business
I know there's lots of great nuggets in
there something I saw from the Amazon
page there are four things in order that
I'm about to read that will guarantee
success I think and this is in the
foreword or something perseverance and
this is in this order or determination
or stamina connection be fun to work
with
and lastly talent really that's the
order yeah that's definitely the order I
mean actually I mean I've in my mind
I've added another one before Talent
which is luck okay luck is definitely
important but yeah you can think about
it some movies get made just because of
perseverance somebody keeps persevering
and though they can get the movie made
and somebody can make a movie because
they have connections you know Sophia
Coppola you know she got to make a movie
she's got incredible connections and
many other people in Hollywood and being
fun to work with
that happens all the time movies get
made because of that but I've never
really seen a movie get made just
because of talent so of all these things
the three the that I started with like
perseverance etc being fun to work with
these are sufficient causes of movies in
other words all you need is one of those
and you're able to make a movie but
talent is not sufficient you have to
have talent plus one of those other
things to make a movie and there's
plenty of talent around the good news I
mean that so that's the bad news talent
is not enough to make a movie but the
good news is that if you have talent
it's what L everybody's looking for in
Hollywood looking for somebody who's
truly tality because they don't want
movies that are just made with
perseverance or being fun to work with
or having connections they want truly
good movies so if you've got talent
that's great but you need to get those
other things you need to persevere it's
not a you know a career for the
faint-hearted you know if you say I'm
going to give myself five years and then
I'm gonna go
- my horse ranch in Utah you'll be back
there before you know it because life
loves little deals like that and it
always gets you back to the horse ranch
if you say that it'll be no limit on my
career I'm going to continue no matter
what then you've got a chance to do it
and maybe you'll get lucky along the way
but I always say build the tracks for
success don't build them based on luck
so yeah that's luck is an important part
of it because sometimes you can have
everything ready to go and somebody
comes out with a similar movie and you
can't do it going back to the school
thought of two types of people
unproductive negative versus positive
what about unhonest talent versus
harness talent and I'm making my little
genre here but people that there's so
much talent here but there's a lot of
people that don't harness it and they
spend their reels talking about these
ideas how does someone go into the
harnessed category well it going to
hardest category just means discipline
to sit down and actually figure out time
and use the time and just you know
determined to do it you have to be
determined you have to persevere there
are a lot of people that have what I
call artistic syndrome who would like to
be creative who say they're creative who
shy whose show some signs of creativity
but creativity is actually having
finished a script you know having
finished a novel and continuing to write
another one while you're waiting for the
reaction on the first one creativity is
like I can't stop writing this I keep
getting stories and I keep can't wait to
get to the next one so you don't really
wait at all when you send it out you you
just now I can do the next one you keep
writing and that's somebody who's
harnessing their talent unhonest means
when you've booby-trapped your talent by
either not sitting down being a fear of
failure or whatever your reasons are
procrastination
you know Tony Robbins always says the
best way to deal with procrastination
correct procrastination is to
just postpone it oh yeah no you can do
that later but right now get to work
so harness talent is all a matter of
discipline and determination you know
starts with determination turns it into
discipline discipline turns into work
work is based on time allotted to it as
the ancient philosopher he's the odd
said if you put a little upon a little
soon it will become a lot that's it you
do five pages a day that's 60 pages you
know after 12 days right so it's it's
just inevitable it's the law of
accumulating capital and if people
aren't doing that then they're they're
completely out hardest and the only
person who can really harness the writer
is himself so you can't nobody can
harness for you you can get a manager to
help you with that you can get a
disciplinarian to help you with it but
at the end of the day there are more
ways to evade discipline than there are
to impose it that's the genius of
humanity right lastly you said something
about being called back to the horse
ranch giving yourself five years someone
just commented on our channel the other
day and they had a very valid point
about give yourself three years they
were referring to acting and I agreed
with a lot of their their statements but
they said they gave up this acting
pursuit and they should have done it
sooner and now they have a corporate job
and things are much better for them
should someone really put this like I
mean my argument was well what if they
know they're never gonna be sort of this
corporate type I mean it takes a certain
type to sit behind a desk or attend
meetings and pretend like you really
want to be there some people aren't cut
out for that and what if you know that
about yourself should you really give
yourself this time limit what if you
know that you're not cut out for the
corporate world yeah their point was
give yourself three years max to come to
LA whatever become an actor you could
insert writing that's that's like saying
give yourself a year to go to Europe and
get your Wild Oats out of your system
before you settle down and
get engaged or something you know if
that's the way you're looking at it then
it will just be a three year lark you
know it's not a career commitment you
know there's a great great moment in a
movie called burlesque I don't know if
you saw that movie but it's Christina
Aguilera isn't it and then one of the
opening scenes in her little town she
goes to the bus station
and she stands in front of the ticket
window and she says I mean I want to
take it to a light and he looks at her
and goes one-way or roundtrip and she
goes you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me
and as it's it's line in the movie that
defines career commitment you know she's
not going to go to LA and come back
she's going to a light period that's the
end of the story and that's why movies
like that in la-la land you know put
artists in tears because they're true
true examples of true stories about what
artists go through when they make
decisions to give up things and you know
I used to give a class and that you see
like all keeping your spirits up for
creative people and one day I was going
around the circle the first day of class
and having people introduce themselves
they were mostly actors and actresses
who signed up for it
for obvious reasons and the first one I
said please give us your name so we'll
remember your name and where you're from
or you know give us your name and where
you're from and what is the tell us what
is the question that you hate to hear
most you know at a party in LA and so
first woman says my name is Carol and
I'm from Detroit and the question I hate
to hear the most is when are you gonna
go back to Detroit and work for the post
office and I said and how do you react
to that she goes usually by bursting
into tears and running out of the room I
go oh okay so we're gonna work on that
in this class so I asked for next class
next person my name is Ellis I'm from
Southern California and the question I
hate to hear the most at parties is what
have you been in big lately that I've
seen
and I said it'd have a director that she
goes I say the Pacific Ocean so there's
an example of a harness person and a nun
harness verse right the hardest person
knows that she's gonna get stupid
questions from stupid people insensitive
people weren't really thinking and that
there's nothing in the world that's
gonna stop that from happening so she's
gonna protect yourself by coming up with
an answer
beforehand so she doesn't have to run
out of the room and cry and the other
person is unhonest cuz she goes out of
the room in Christ she's the one that
believes this artistry thing is some
magic you know miracle that has to
happen and she doesn't understand it's
mechanical you know first thing you have
to do is protect your biggest asset
which is your brain and if you haven't
figured out how to do that then don't go
out in public yet because people are not
gonna stop start suddenly being
sensitive the moment you appear in
public they've never shown any sign of
it in the human history right I always
loved this book I read ago years ago as
a graduate student call it began in
Babel the history of the world you know
told with uh since of humor and m'p and
half of the book at the beginning is
when you really think about it people on
the whole are extremely stupid and it's
a carving on the walls of Nineveh 3200
BC and it's kind of comforting to read
that because you go well nothing's
changed
you know we're still there we're still
stupid and you know that's part of the
human comedy but don't be stupid if it's
your you know your whole career at stake
you're the one has to build the you know
use the tools to build a defense around
yourself so you can continue your career
and people are not going to help you
until they see that you've got that
figured out then they'll help you and
it's just the way they are that goes
back to what you said about the sort of
crackpot neighbor in the garage making
these paintings and then everyone thinks
they're crazy until they sell one for a
million or two and then all of a sudden
everyone wants to know them so yeah
everyone thinks you're a genius and
and and predicts and said I always knew
you would do well like my father told me
I was an idiot when I became a professor
like he didn't understand how I was
gonna make a living because I didn't
sign up for pre-med I signed up for
classics in college and 19 years later
when I told him I was leaving being a
professor for you know being a producer
he told me how it's crazy that how was I
going to make a living and in four weeks
later he was on the set of one of my
movies and said this is great keep doing
this thing host so if you put a lot of
truck on what other people think you'll
be a mess all your life and one of the
things I really hate to see is someone
who is all about just pleasing people
and will say whatever they need to say
to please the people in front of them
and then you know you realize they don't
have a mind of their own and that's
that's too bad too bad to lose your life
too to spend your life without a mind of
your own
it's a terrible a mind is a terrible
thing to lose as they say and the writer
is somebody I think who's exploited
their mind to the to the max and and
take it you know followed its lead into
places that it would never have imagined
they would go and I think that's heroic
you know heroic way of life
and and the world needs more
storytellers
you